but yeah i have a tama impala as well i
love tame impala my favorite album is
the slow rush not the other one that
everyone uh that you see everywhere and
everyone's talking about currents yeah
yeah that everyone is a good album i
love slow rush breathe deeper is like my
favorite song for damon paula i love
that [ __ ] song
i don't know driving to tame impala is
like
another level of enjoying it i don't
know why have you listened to his side
project pond no you all right if you
liked him and paul you'll like that it's
probably pretty well it's just tame and
power but harder will youtube recommend
it to me i'll find out probably not
basically that's how my music is decided
have the algorithm gods decided
if so yes i'll listen but unfortunately
sometimes it recommends me uh
artists there's like one song i really
like and i check out the other stuff and
i'm like
yeah there's lots of honestly that
happens like that who is the one on the
left there above bo burnham oh this is
uh you know them uh snail's house all
snacks oh is that snail's house yeah i
love it
no lyrics let's go yeah i didn't i
didn't recognize the art yeah i love
snails house uh it's probably like
if i can encapsulate all my i guess i
don't even if it's a disservice to call
it weeby music it's kind of like it's
it is
nostalgic gaming it's it's a subculture
of like weeby he's half japanese
yeah like we be nerdy [ __ ] i i like how
we've been noticing i like how this one
makes me feel i like this one yeah i i
there was a phase
there was a phase in my life where i
feel like i listened how does it make
you feel happy i want to say happily
emotionally yeah so there was like
before i moved to japan i want to say i
listened to this for like god like a
whole year straight away were you
prepping your japan visit with somebody
before i even decided japan
and then weirdly it was like yeah i just
love this album a lot not on this album
sorry i love all of his songs yeah uh
absolutely all bangers all kind of
different moods even though like it's
the same style yeah i like how it it
doesn't always feel the same there's a
bunch of variations shout out to snell's
house banging if you like anime music or
anything like that or like electronic
you'll probably like this it's really
good yeah i call i call this genre a
weeb core
weeb core
it's weeb daft punk yeah question mark
how do you do this
how does anthony fantano do this what
the [ __ ] is he doing
to say a lot of adjectives
words
this is like how i describe this music
it's like it's like if you go to an
artist
if you go to an artist alley in any
convention and put that and take that
experience put that in the genre of
music that is like that's weeble
basically right it's not an anime you
know that feeling before you go to a
convention
obviously not now because you're
miserable adults but yeah you know a few
earlier a few years earlier when you're
like kind of excited you're like bubbly
you're like oh yeah it's so exciting
that's the feeling like [ __ ] shoved
it into a job that i can just like any
time i want i can just take a oh
snail's house to me is like what it must
sound like to live in the kirby universe
yes
that's what it sounds like to me it's
like [ __ ] your enemies come up yeah
everything is like everything everything
is like
a good sock on everything it's like
everything is like round and like bubbly
and pastel colored and like overly happy
i could fall over but the floor is made
of marshmallows
that's like in a good way not in like no
no no no not like a conduct anyway
yeah it's just like it's pillowy yeah
dude it's great yeah such a great if you
wanna if you wanna be you know feel
happy and have a good time and you you
wanna feel vibes try snail's house and
you don't lyrics because i'm honestly
sometimes like should get in the way
sometimes
yeah no i do sometimes i just sometimes
someone who doesn't even listen to
lyrics i feel something missing without
vocal tracking we could talk about that
we could we can talk about other picks
that we can talk about the other one i
want to talk about i love the weekend
and this is a weird one because i for
very long very very long time just kind
of felt indifferent towards the weekend
i felt like it was that artist that just
always got like number ones but like
right you know it's kind of like
whatever but then like the last album
came out and i was like okay no no this
is all fire this is all like really
[ __ ] good okay i think he's actually
like insane and then i went back and
listened to the other stuff i i
appreciated it way more now yeah yeah
seeing how far he's grown and how how
much his albums have like just improved
no i'm definitely i was definitely the
same i was like oh this is just like
another the generic pop guy
exactly exactly and because like when i
listen to house of balloons which is his
first album i was like ah this is like
it's good but it's like nothing special
and then after alice came out with like
blinding lights like that album i was
like okay okay i see you i see it and
then the new album was like all right
solidified you're pretty good dude this
this album it's been like out for like i
don't know like two months at this point
and i've literally just listened to that
album non-stop it's so good i think the
weekend actually is right now the most
streamed artist on spotify it wouldn't
surprise number one right now like this
album has so many bangers that like it's
it's so fun talking about this album to
people because everyone i spoke to has a
different favorite song yeah it's not
like other albums where it's like okay
everyone likes uh ex-song the most and
it's very predictable it's like everyone
is just telling me about other songs
they like them yeah like oh yeah that
one is a banger that's that's the best
kind of artist though right where it's
like
it's like you can't pick like a top like
i would think it's really difficult for
someone like the weekend to make like a
greatest hits album yeah because it's
like which songs do we not put in that
album right true because every song is
great also i love that like i wasn't
paying attention to lyrics but then i
started actually paying attention to the
lyrics this current album i'm like [ __ ]
man this is really [ __ ] sad yeah why
why is what's going on with this man
he's like yeah i've got to see a woman
and she's [ __ ] another man
i'm so sad that she's [ __ ] another
man and it's like what
what
he's like i loved her and then she
stepped on my heart and i'm like whoa
while an 80s like funk basically plays
in the background but it's so good
though it's so good it's so good
oh my god
it's
how often do you listen to like music
lyrics in
songs
so what makes you listen to the lyrics
in this song
so many times after a point i started
like just
he would say stuff and i was like hold
up
rewind rewind that really what's that
hold up
i'm like jesus christ
oh my god
we're his therapist you know we're just
hearing it yeah exactly and bo burnham
you know bo burnham was one of those
things where
you kind of have to listen to the lyrics
to enjoy the music
and
it really made me
see that like okay because to me
comedy music before was like just
uh [ __ ] lonely island
yeah yeah yeah like weirdo the younger
thing but not really yeah yeah i mean
it's it was like parody music yeah where
they were kind of for me it would like
they would take a song or like an
established like genre of music and just
kind of like parody that
um on like a surface level if that makes
sense and and tim mentioned it's
obviously very everyone always yeah yeah
but like even that the music i wasn't
like super into but i don't know when i
was i've watched by burnham specials
like uh all of them like at least four
plus times now and i just love it to
death yeah and i really like the songs
they're really funny but also really
good some of them are like absolute
bangers yeah yeah um i love the one at
the end of uh make happy you've got the
one where it is but it's when he's
talking about burritos and putting the
hand in the pringle can i come
[Music]
down
but it's so good though because it's
like it starts off as a joke and then it
turns into this whole you know the
struggle of being a creator and what
people expect things from you and how do
you struggle with that you know and as
uh as somebody who creates stuff it was
like oh [ __ ] whoa this is [ __ ]
wow this is weird yeah did you ever like
get into lonely island though back in
the day i loved lonely island
when i was like 14 i thought this ship
was like peak comedy and music and i was
like i was like oh my god he threw it on
the ground oh my dude oh my god he put a
dick in a box like what the [ __ ]
this show she's talking about
yeah yeah
damn man this song is about three sons
you know
because i was a kid and i thought she
was hilarious like yeah i just had sex i
thought that was like the peak comedy
for me it was like i'm on a boat
i just had t-pain in there for no
[ __ ] reason um it was it was that and
like a boss yeah like a boss
those were like the most viewed [ __ ]
videos on youtube yeah yeah yeah and
they were like i i literally i remember
i have this weird memory of me playing
black ops one and just playing lonely
island songs on repeat wow and i
literally did nothing but listen to the
loneliness everyone was like that in the
early stages though it was like bo
burnham is like it kind of took the best
of like comedy and then added it with
like amazing funny uh stand up with
amazing lyrics and great and i love the
song
it's like one minute long it's the
[ __ ] jeff bezos song from inside i
[ __ ] love that one you gotta listen
to it because
i've only seen inside but like obviously
it's one of the few artists where i did
listen to the songs because he is like i
guess i don't know how you'd categorize
or put
like how do you categorize these kind of
songs but it's like it's like comedy
songs but it also like it he's his songs
also make you think yeah yeah like the
message kind of like sticks with you
it's funny and deep
i think the best of both
is it too deep for you i don't know but
uh it's the evangelion of comedy music
shut the [ __ ] up
i'm kidding i'm kidding yeah i know i
want to put it on so i wanted to talk
about it and i thought that it was
really interesting
you know there's a lot of artists i
could have put on